deuxième constatation il ya 90% de quoi
en dispensant deux frères mes frères
mais chez les femmes c'est gratiné j'ai
rencontré des esprits si payant chez les
femmes mais 1% et un ramassis de kaunas
je ne te dis que ça c'est quand des
choses qu'on peut si vous voulez me
venger sa map apaisement mais je lui
saute et nous passions pour des
dégueulasse parce que de temps en temps
que tel ou quand elle nous en imposent
au hockey ciao
au revoir ok bah finalement il tient
parfaitement la bouteille ce guide
américain voulait pas entendre et là
monsieur monsieur tout il fallait y
mettre fin dès mais de l'autre il a
porté ses bouteilles la montée si vous
souhaitez rester la télévision qui
l'ignorent mois il a porté lui-même ses
boutons prépare pour apporter son manger
moi j'ai pas tellement au fond bon
soyons tous tolérant vous avez cette
vision des femmes c'est votre droit
d'autres peuvent avoir une autre vision
de la femme je change de voiliers
mince c'est différent oui j'ai demandé
ce qu'ils ont sorti l'égal des hommes
mais je pense qu'il faut pas confondre
légalité et d'identité